hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to dream daddy now we
just are starting the new day full of
opportunities to make as many mistakes
as we could ever hope and hopefully meet
some new dreamy daddies along the way
anyway
mornings leaving in five more minutes
you have never ever let me have five
more minutes to get up flying God oh we
have cereal for breakfast and spend the
morning putting together furniture man
is much better at interpreting the tiny
manuals we're able to go together a few
shelves in one desk but I'm pretty sure
it was supposed to be a joke you excited
for the cookout today Oh excited to beef
up my grilling skills yeah I'll see this
is a learning opportunity if I can snake
some hot grill tips I think we can
consider it a success huh don't you want
to meet some of the other people in the
neighborhood probably end up standing
uncomfortably in the corner with a plate
of food and hopefully nobody talks to me
dad you're a beautiful work in progress
we will get that butterfly to emerge
from the cocoon the social butterfly
well we better start getting ready they
definitely don't want to be rude what we
have to be fashionably late who shows up
to check out on time you know what we're
going early because you said and out the
door and Amanda reluctantly follows we
walk around streets of Joseph salad with
a store-bought veggie plate I'm a
terrible cook it doesn't involve a grill
guess we're not as early as we thought
Joseph's backyard is already packed with
people that smelled not dogs wafts
through the air small children run
through a sprinkler in adults chat and
small cluster I said our veggie blade
down on a table next to two other veggie
plates huh hey miss Joseph a way to get
his attention the moment he sees us he
John's over arms open wide welcome I'm
so glad you two are here you brought
veggies let me introduce you to my
family kids come on over here this is
Chris my eldest hi it's Christian and
Christy they're twins they stare
creepily and say nothing
all righty then then of course there's
our youngest Krish wait Chris Krish
maybe Mary put him in his crib oh no
it's a woman from the bar last night
what's she doing here
Oh and how could I forget my lovely
wife Mary home Joseph XR on the cheek
she smiles ah Mary sweetheart
did you put Krish to bed I'll have to go
look for him
what you'll have to just takes a moment
to regain its composure Mary this is our
new neighbour markings daughter Amanda
oh I check your hand but I have a glass
of wine that I needed then - I love her
nice to meet you Mary for the first time
charmed well I have to go over there now
we're leaves okay let's talk ER or if
Joseph knows or of Mary knows - Joseph
knows or if Joseph knows and Mary's
knows that I know they call my energy
not to run away from the barbecue and
start fresh in a new city my wife has a
wonderful sense of humor but he please
you to enjoy the barbecue all the guys
are really excited to meet you
Wow I think I've actually met everybody
else oh great
I bet you're excited to get to know
everyone better hope you both have enjoy
yourselves man and I'm Milla run try
some food a spread out on table I pick
out some deviled eggs Amanda grabs a
small paper plate and immediately begins
piling it with baked goods I don't want
to have to make new friends come on dad
are you gonna party with when I got to
school I don't want to have to do the
blood dad they're gonna talk about
whether oh do it make a friend but I
probably am and my only child at a
social function that's bad parent let's
play the cookies with my new dad bye and
she'll be in the center yard well
there's nothing I look around the yard
of her right to see some killer fish hi
the party here oh right I don't remember
your name is that the barista from the
coffee spoon oh dang Roberts here Oh God
he still hasn't been brooding and dark
Oh
didn't that guy throw a frisbee in my
head isn't that the guy who was throwing
a bit and dead goth and beyond
isn't that Amanda's teacher yeah I know
Craig wait a second all these people
live in our cul-de-sac that can't be
right better investigate
I'm gonna tell Burger Time burger burger
diamond without further ado let's work
some magic
Justin closes his eyes and takes a deep
breath and gets to work with the
greatest of ease we sent patties on the
grill flourishing and he flips a spatula
in the air it's easily some of the best
grill work I've ever seen man you could
flip me any day
you guys think this is my first time in
front of a grill he's working bathroom
now and effortlessly tossing cheese on
the pad you can perfect grilled onions
on the side one after another the dads
take notes in the crowd around Joseph
new admirers masterful technique Wow you
probably didn't know this mark Joseph
known around here for his grills Manship
he's unreal laughable I've tried to get
on his level but I just can't catch up
let us keep studying nice flog round
he's a rare quality about him I'm not
mustard we keep talking about this how
do we just appreciate the artiste hey
I've never seen it make mistake mmm okay
we need to stop this is getting too
cheesy
yeah please stop all the children's the
party boo the glorious display of puns
in unison all right guys the food's
ready please form an orderly barbecue ha
ha I'm into grunt we all grab our food
and hang out and doing perfectly cooked
Jesus man it's a wild out all of us
dad's living the same cul-de-sac dining
nice isn't it it's like there's a real
community here totally helps when you're
just a single dad trying to raise a kid
we're happy to have you here man
I think you're gonna like his
neighborhood a lot hmm Plus Amanda seem
to be getting along with one of the kids
she decides to get into the babysitting
game she'll really make a killing hey
why don't you add us all on that book
that book yeah it's a great social
network for dads to keep in touch with
each other we're all in it so if you
ever need to reach out to anyone that's
the simplest way to do this all right
I'm just an old-fashioned bad social
media goes over my head sometimes don't
worry pops
I'll help you figure it out the rest of
the bdq goes smoothly we all straight
stories and drink beer as our kids play
on the lawn amanda breaks up a fight
between Carmencita in those weird twins
I think they wanted her soul man and I
walked back to our places the Sun sets
over the neighborhood pretty fun party
don't you think oh man wish I could have
been playing paranormal ice road drugs
yeah now I mean I got a burger in me
somehow or one way or another a burger
is in me sweetie if I can impart any
sort of whiz
on you right now and not that face was a
bad situation but if you're ever in an
uncomfortable situation always look for
the silver lining the silver linings get
you through to the other side
we ate rocking Berg's today and it was
good amen
well hey at least you met some other
cool dad's you should hit them up on dad
book maybe I will if I ever figure out
how social media works I have a good
feeling about this place
me too dad me too
oh man and I arrived home with the
remnants of her veggie plate seems like
nobody was really into the cauliflower I
love cold any big plans for this evening
actually yeah I'm going out with some
friends oh okay
of course just keep me posted and be
home before midnight
mm got it be careful I will good choices
of course call me if you need anything
yeah dad you're not going to do the
thing where you wait silently for me to
come Oh in the living room with all the
lights turned up are you what no I've
never done that now we'll never do it
totally going to do that tonight do you
have plans tonight I'm going to sit in
the living room with all the lights off
waiting for you to come home with a
shotgun in my lap my plans were going to
eat ice cream and watch TV with Amanda
but I'll find something to do good for a
party that's me I'm a party car dad dad
heart applier let's be well throw a
party a real rager all the other dad's
in the neighborhood are invited don't
see if I can give you a spot on the list
but obviously it's looking tight you may
just have to wait lying I know the guy
at the door I'll get in no problem just
relaxing tonight have fun okay great see
you later watch a man to drive off into
the night I really hope feels fun makes
good choices I'll be here in the dark
with a shotgun waiting for you to come
home
I walked down from the TV and turn on
some wine and dine mastermind with
celebrity chef Gavin Chapman looks like
Gavin's making a roasted rack of lamb
with rosemary mashed potatoes oh it's so
good
I'd love to be able to cook like that
although I think if I was actually good
at cooking I use my powers for evil like
just making baked Alaska's all day
instead of any food of real nutritional
substance man Gavin Chapman just caught
that thing on fire but he meant to do it
what a professor I lose track of time is
that blazed through several episodes of
Windham dying mastermind and also one
episode of some cooking show called meat
hell not even sure what that one was
about it was just a lot of yelling the
glance of my watch
man it's almost midnight I should check
in with Amanda's I send a text hey kiddo
you good hello a little wandering to the
kitchen as I wait my reply man his phone
is almost always in her hand so I'm
chilled response soon when she's driving
home now in which case I hope she
doesn't respond soon because I
definitely told her not to pictogram
reach into the freezer and grab an Ice
Cream Sandwich late for this but I think
I earned it after a long day of shooting
I check my watch again and then my phone
nothing yet okay see now I'm worried too
a caller gonna call the cops no no you
stupid I've sent her a gentle reminder
text with a picture of me in the dark
with my shotgun what's up hey how's it
going y'all with all the habit house
half an hour past now I'm really worried
the episodes of Gavin Chapman's me hell
are not the only thing that's waging my
anxiety possibly exacerbating it with
all the yelling so I keep pacing around
the house waiting for her to come back
why didn't I find out where she was
going but even with what Daniel fella
why don't I ever intro numbers why do I
even know where French Holdings we've a
map II I just signed us enter another
tech Amanda please text me let me know
you're okay and I would think of all the
awful things that could have happened to
her oh my god it's her man opens the
door and shuffles in finally finally
she's back home shut up weenie thank god
you're safe yep now that I know she's
okay I'm really mad why didn't you
answer my texts
Amanda pulls our phone Avril pocket oh
whoops guess I didn't see those start to
walk to a room Amanda enough
oh we're pulling out the middle lane now
Amanda you came home an hour and a half
after your curfew and you didn't respond
to any my texts you really freaked me
out I was about to call the cops
dad you're seriously overreacting you're
not gonna be like this when I go up to
school are you let's see I have a right
to be concerned you're my only daughter
well I can't give you a play-by-play of
everything I do all the time I'm 18 you
shouldn't even be able to give me a
curfew in the first place I sit down on
the couch and put my head in my hands I
feel very tired also really scared just
please don't do that again all right I'm
gonna go to bed now mana close the door
to a room and I had to mine geez as I'm
falling asleep one thing she said keeps
echoing in my mind not going to be like
this when I go up to school are you I
definitely didn't sleep well last night
at brew some strong coffee and make some
scrambled eggs for Amanda as a peace
offering eventually wanders into the
kitchen Hey
thought about what you said last night I
should have texted you I was gonna do it
I didn't she just didn't even think
about it
really sorry possible do it again well I
trust you to make good choices I also
thought about it I'll try to give you
your space from here on out I gotta
trust that you can take care of yourself
hmm
team applier team applier team applier
yeah give a player in the house all
everyone of us yeah all together big
family yeah I'm not cool am i man who
gives me a hug want some eggs
you know it sprinkle some cheese on
already did ah bless you man scarf down
the eggs in time to pick me a washing
pan all right in my schools no you later
wait one more thing Prevot what what's
dad's ball the social media platform
wait one what the social media platform
yeah hamburger school come on man I'm an
old man I can't put together a dad book
profile on my own all right I'll help
you sound interesting man you spend the
next couple minutes setting up my
Brooklyn dad book which as it turns out
is a play where dad's can get together
and talk about father all right pops we
got fill you out your profile is because
the likes and dislikes
hmm I'm ready for this Oh on a Friday
night you're most likely to Oh
polishing sort my coin fiction Netflix
in grill baby alls Lee watching this is
where you can torment my children with
dead buns thinking too blissful oblivion
sleep this is this are you familiar with
I don't know if that's a euphemism
Netflix and Grill baby all CDs torment
my children with dad buns I'm gonna go
with the dad buns
who doesn't like if you had one thing to
take with you on to a desert island what
would it be see my trusty grill a lost
shaker of salt haha I get that
Goss away on DVD for instructional
purposes a boat obviously I don't need
anything much survivals girls would
drain me for this day well grill what's
that going to do for you can't you're
not gonna have enough gas lost shaker
assault whatever you're signed by an
ocean you can just dry out some sea get
sea salt
castaway on DVD you wouldn't have a DVD
player and I would you so that'd be
stupid a boat oh good you got fuel for
that boat how are you going to get in
the ocean if it's on the island you're
gonna drag it out oh you're gonna do
that Oh real smart with you oh is it a
rowboat oh that's not gonna survive on
the ocean you didn't think this through
obviously didn't think it's through
survival skills training for this day
what are your turn-ons strong dad arms
huh
tennis shoes with long white socks well
manicured lawn street smarts top tier
grill moonship comfort
that's not my journal there's not I turn
on guys I'm gonna go with strong dad
arms real strong real strong what didn't
you want to be when you grew up
let's see technical writer for manuals
and instructions salty boat captain hell
yes prosecutors also an astronaut the
pregnant of space wanting to be the
president of space what's your favorite
movie genre war documentaries Sean
Connery's entire filmography anything on
laserdisc romantic comedies whatever
will make you cry old Tommy's do happen
aged well I would ago anything on
laserdisc
like that what's your ideal date napping
together doing a thousand because elite
ahead in ER at 4 p.m. trying a geocache
been getting hopelessly lost arson being
emotionally vulnerable
I like the idea of geocache you just go
you really do you just get hopelessly
lost but sounds fun
what do you never leave home without a
sensible cardigan my sick fade my book
of word jumbles and a pen a cool knife
my cripplingly low self-esteem how many
of my crippling lis low self-esteem I
just can't leave home without it I spent
a lot of time thinking about
bearsy theories how proud I am of my job
potential end of the world vomit if I'll
ever be able to love myself as much as
look my grill what I can give next
couple gobby lawnmower modification oh
let's play oh I'll never be able to love
myself as much as I love my grill my
girls a euphemism robach ibly see that
wasn't so bad yeah that was actually
kind of fun
I can totally spend all day on you're
just looking at people's profiles you
should message me one of them or more
than one of them all these dad seemed
pretty interesting okay I promise I'll
make some friends Amanda gives me a ha
go get him dad more welcome whoa God dad
I've got dad look at all these dads oh
[ __ ] oh I didn't want to like Craig but
I like Craig mmm Hugo's he's interested
that's cool Brian's a Sweetarts Roberts
brooding though probably has a soft
intercourse Damien's weird Joseph Joseph
has some family things going on there
I'm gonna go Craig reunite was good old
Craig here hey Craig Craig dad a3
business opportunity and fitness
enthusiast juggling work family and
fitness is a tough gig but someone got
do it on a Friday night most likely to
get one last good cardio session in if
you had to take something with you on
desert island would it be a box of
energy bars where your turn-ons a sub
six-minute mile what do you want to be
when you grew up a beer pong world
champion what's your favorite movie
buddy cop movies forever oh hell yeah oh
hell yeah cue hot floods any day what's
your ideal date scaling a huge dangerous
noun for fun
what do you never leave home without an
extra tube of energy gel right then I
spent a lot of time thinking about my
mild time used to be so good what
than have i peek oh my god oh you read
everyone's proof willing we avid music
enthusiasts passion coffee drinker you
can find me most days selling beans you
scott don't call it bean juice hanging
out at the park with my amazing daughter
hit me up about 80s no wave music
perfect cold brew one trip at a time
baby
fine tunes to pass a day away
multi-instrumental ism a barista weirdly
enough [ __ ] with subtitles go to the
animal shelter and seriously consider
adopting a cat that was a dog I'd be
right there with you my headphones both
in here and over here just in case we're
do writing comments into the song tales
come from where did it go we all just
agree that it's a bad idea
Oh Brian what's good Brian hi I'm Brian
I'd like to spend most of my days
hanging out with my awesome daughter and
thinking I'm new at the grilled things
if you like fishing and we'll get along
on a Friday see I'll just how slowly I
can cook a piece of brisket if you had
one thing to take with you on an island
what would it be of my fishing pole very
smart
what do you turn on the keen
understanding of steak cuts would you
want to be when you grew up a fireman
romantic comedies deck-building I used
to build decks
that's literally that was my job for two
years what do you never leave home
without my portable fishing pole spent a
lot of time thinking about how my
daughter is smart a knife Oh cute all
right okay Robert why is he on here when
the internet gained sentience and
decides to throw us all you know it'll
use this information against us right
Friday night make a deal in an alleyway
have it go badly who's the cop who's
Giacomo
I trust Giacomo was a gam oh I don't
know if you had to take one thing what
would be a gun
turn-ons don't talk to me what do you
want to be gripped her favorite movie
John Italian Neorealism
with your idea bakery robbing at least
four knives you never look really look
into a rabid animals eyes all right fine
then Damian well as Damian how do you do
I finally decided to join the
information superhighway not entirely
sure how this works but I will try my
best to understand I love long strolls
to graveyards and spending time with my
son if you would ever like to chat about
the ladies Victorian fashion the
inevitability of our own demise of black
cats please send me a letter
Friday nights listen to two con podcasts
while I taxidermy latest species for my
newest specimens take one thing with you
a coffin what are your turn-ons
pronouncing boo zoom correctly bow zoom
bosom what did you want to be when you
grew up a bat favorite movie for an
arthouse horror ideal date it's night we
are at an industrial darkwave Club in
Berlin the music drums to the beat of
our hearts what do you never leave an
upside-down cross spend a lot of time
thinking about mortality salience gay
Hugo middle school teacher high school
teacher variety of scholarly articles in
the 18th century literature and various
esteemed publications if you're here to
tell me that my son put a cherry bomb in
your trash I know and I'm sorry
Friday and I brew some strong tea and
paint my miniatures if you had to take
one thing with you a remembrance of
things past by Marco Prost
turn-ons our muscles grew up wanted to
be a movie star every movie gonna
documentaries in our history ideal date
each of us read a different book on
opposite sides with couch and
comfortable silence that's a pretty damn
good to me I've been doing a lot of
reading lately when you never leave home
without my glasses actually I forget
them at home a lot spent a long time
thinking about I worry that people who
are against Erie ders are more in love
with the idea of books and actually
reading them Oh smart man smart man
smart man jeez Oh Vega all right Joseph
what do you got voted maple Bay's number
one you've Minister over five years
running living in my hometown with my
beautiful wife enough four amazing kids
if I'm not in church you can catch me
out in the open water setting sail on
the Seas of adventure I love playing
guitar and crushing my kids at Candyland
Friday night lead the community and a
fund mixer my sixth string my loving
wife is your turn on aah that's weird
what did you want to be when you grew up
ship captain me too
what's the favorite movie genre
feel-good movies ideal date lovely night
on town with my wife what do you never
leave home without bill good book I can
spend a lot of time thinking about how
it can be a better man husband and
father
oh that's too good to be true nothing
about that can be possibly right your
last name is Christians I'm gonna go
with Craig Craig can Craig can let's go
Craig hey Craig the only acceptable time
and place for decaf coffee is never and
in the track hi how dare you what all
Craig's up to be there and now
- Craig's dad book page and type out a
message hey bro or should I say neighbor
let's catch up like the old time out of
my boobie no couple moments pass before
I hear a ding in the computer it's a
mention from Craig Dana oh my man simply
hangs you might be a little different
from our old weekend long fenders but it
would still be fun right
it sends a couple more messages and he
logs out the preppers full game I should
see if a man who wants to join me I
walked over to Amanda's room and knock
on the door yo man fanda open the door
and find man two sitting cross-legged on
the floor surrounded by magazines
newspaper clippings so here's the man
making some sort of art piece her eyes
are a little puffy almost as if she'd
been crying hey you alright
oh yeah I'm fine it's got a because I
realized the dogs are too often killed
off in movies to elicit emotional
reaction from the audience instead of
being given the respect that they
deserve
alright are you sure there's you know
anything going on y-you know that I'm
here for you and I'll always be here for
you but they need a shoulder to cry on
or a strong dad to go pick someone but
I'm only a phone call away huh thank
popsicle appreciate that but I'm fine
really
I'm unconvinced but I'll stop badgering
sure she'll tell me when she's ready but
you're working on just a collage for
class we're supposed to make a piece of
represents our goals for the future
let's take a closer look at her collage
that's a lot of dogs fuzzy dogs yeah do
you need something
Rick invited us through a softball game
want to go remember that one time you
signed me up for softball and you bought
me all the gear and then you judge me
for the first game then someone hit a
ball towards me and I ran off the screen
Gil crying you're hitting the dugout and
would scream if I tried to pick you up
yeah I remember that
what's a parade of baseball I thought
you were a gigantic sentient soft does
that mean you don't want to go Dana gets
up and looks me dead in the eyes eternal
kind of ready to face my career's head
on let's do this okay all right then man
I make short drive out to the local
softball field for a kid's softball game
it's pretty backed clamber up to the
bleachers and take our seats on the top
row and one see Greg anywhere why do the
kids are crying and running off into the
field you know that your relationship
with softball is different from anyone
elses relationship right
not everyone does okay but if I don't
see some goods crime gonna be pretty
this point for nostalgic purposes of
course not because they take joy out of
children fighting for mine hmm
definitely not that game start some kid
runs off to the field I see Craig by the
dugout with the clipboard his River
strapped to his chest as per usual the
guy in a pancake costume doing jumping
jacks across a field I guess that's a
minute Scott we ain't reading the kids
brightly colored jerseys I see it's a
maple baked flapjacks against the time
wood ocelots go flapjacks choke up on
the bat Miranda yeah Miranda square up
once you know about subtle enough to
note that the balls are relatively hard
despite the name yelling is fun the shot
it's gets Arctic keep your eye on the
ball
what's important is that your habit find
them what are you willing to sacrifice
to win we've had a beer and we want to
play sorry my neighbors broad you not
appreciate that array they do maybe
they're encouraged by exactly why seem
to be Miranda's father gives me a dirty
look
i shooed it back at him that adds to
this is gonna bring Miranda to division
one dad please don't find any other dads
while we're out here
we watch a couple innings of softball
they aren't ready for the majors yeah
Craig's trained it seemed pretty well
seems like he's really good with kids
Dex Dan Craig is good with children
amazing how hard they're hitting the
ball no one has to run off the field
crying in man is dear you have to let it
go the opposing team is up and back they
hit a flyball on surf field tiny little
girl tried to get on the ball but misses
or club and it's straightened for it see
it's completely justifiable fear girl
plops down in the grass to charge crying
Craig makes a plea line for her checking
her forehead and comforting her until
the parents arrived he carries her off
the field as she saw that would be quite
a hit pop fly right to the forehead for
a little girl whoo man strange to think
about how this was a guy was back
flipped off a roof and into a pool of
shotgun and a beer he's so responsible
got that sketchy shot so cool
wish I could be half as cool as Craig
Craig school dammit game resumes after
the girl calms down a bit and we watched
couple more innings
Craig team is crushing the other team in
the ninth inning the Ocelot seemed to
have given up at this point I see one
outfielder eating a fistful of grass a
batter on the other team knocks foul
ball into the stands
I follow the trajectory in it's coming
right for me no no no Oh pickle advise
brace for impact
Craig saved me Greg saves me Greg I open
my eyes and look over to see a man
holding the softball staring at it
amazed well you saved me caught the ball
dad I caught the ball did it Amanda face
my fears I defeated the softball I can
do anything man and I share big hug it's
a tender moment that I don't think
anyone else watching really understood
I'm proud of you kiddo
gay man's a Craig steamer declared the
victors you sit patiently as the girls
lined up to shake hands great job
everyone
walk over to the dugout and congratulate
Craig is standing talking with some of
the parents Greg wait work bad Thanks
been working hard all season
that's great see paying off so proud of
all my girls being butch if you met
Brier and Hazel hello hi briar i hazel
hey killer playing out there yeah you
got this rule thank you
get us a twins huh so which one of you
is the evil one hazel yeah it's me good
looking out you guys ever pretend to be
each other I don't have a twin but I
think if I did I'd do that constantly
yeah I take all over math tests I
usually throw rocks and stuff and when
people get mad I tell him I'm Brier what
we'll talk about this later talk about
this later
mark bro I just got a couple more oh my
god he's wearing pajama pants [ __ ] I
love [ __ ] wearing goddamn [ __ ] Oh
God aah sorry I'm wearing pants today
but guys it's destiny Greg mark bro then
we can hang sound good just man one of
the moms jumps into the conversation not
so fast we have to celebrate our win
Craig I'm taking the whole team to get
people in I don't know if I can
nonsense the girls won what's or a
celebration could we have without our
fearless leader she lays her hand on a
shoulder and give them goo-goo eyes man
this mom is laying it on thick man I
Cheryl
all right all right is it cool with my
bro comes along mom looks slightly put
out but covers it up with a smile of
course
where we going Thirsty's pizza Wow huh
it's a real place an endless stream of
girls clad in softball gear piling a
minivan and into a local pizza buffet
which is actually called Thirsty's pizza
then I trail behind them with Greg
reminds me of all the awful people we
put on our bodies back in the day
remember we used to just fold up whole
pies in half and then put taco fillings
inside Oh Pete tacos I'll never forget
how do we survive college our bodies
were younger back then more elastic more
able to handle the toxic waste we put
inside of us all the good old days it's
running around playing arcade games and
even reaching food man and I run up a
couple of slices of media creams give me
a pizza bit no absolutely not
I'm just kidding I'm strictly eating
salad here thanks for addressing the
issue Amanda dad different mom walks up
to it talking to Craig as if we weren't
even there rag thank you so much for
looking after our kids my daughter tells
me every day about how great I'm happy
to look after them definitely helps it
I've kids in my house it's been so hard
since Daniel left I'm glad to know that
my children in their strong growing male
role model
man I look at each other again Craig
gets it from all angles huh
Greg smile cheaper sweetie thank you so
much dude rec holds his fist up for a
fist bump from the mom and fixes a
maneuver to lighten the conversation
it looks super uncomfortable I from a
bone here you see smokescreen Martha
create a diversion tag team with Amana I
created diversion but anyway I mean I'm
going to throw myself on to the arcade
machines but the first things come to
mind
what's long-haul paranormal eyes were go
to read this book what Kalman Flynt
dog-bone visit a truck shop that was
also a cemetery and led an exorcism of
ghosts I was hunting the hot dog grill I
know Amanda for sport it was also a
demon haunting one of the bathroom
stalls and it kept throwing poop on the
wall
pretty scary stuff actually now that I
think about this good chance it was a
non paranormal explanation for that but
still quality tablets
I haven't seen that I've seen that
either wow we have so much in common she
turns her back on me to talk to crack so
I'm talking taking hazel and briar
tonight for the sleepover yep they're
pretty excited about you'll keep them
out of trouble right of course but I
could always use help with watching
after everyone tonight not doing
anything not just laying is really going
for a game huh you'll actually be nice
to have a night for myself and River
thanks for the invite
Martha you might want to grab your child
she's stuffing Pete is going plot or the
angrily turns our attention towards our
daughter differently not another arcade
machine I swear if I have to buy it
well the storms off towards her kid she
seems nice
yeah the team is one big weird family
takes all sorts right Tiffany don't even
be tokens Tiffany the stellar hitter I
don't think I have time to talk to Craig
now and your busy guy huh only on days
like today Oh dad
hey girls dad can you help us beat a
record on DDR I told Ariana stab me you
can destroy him on the dance mat please
help you know I don't have my dukes
anymore what yeah looks at me a little
like a hurt a little pump sorry dude
duty calls I promise we'll catch up in a
bit oh he crying you're sweating it's
all good buddy sectarian runs off with
his daughter and I'm left alone with
mine and I was really hoping to hang out
Craig more today it seems like he's
getting dragged in every direction
definitely wasn't like this in college
like me might be a third wheel here well
his worst place is in an arcade to be
left to your own devices right wanna
drop some corn on pinball did you know
it man and I pull up to the machine
that's feeling pretty hot and get to
work I'm a little rusty but the pinball
wizard within me never died pull out a
decent score and then challenge Amanda
to top mine and immediately again she
gets a multi ball so she takes after her
father pretty good Oh patronize me hey
just trying to pay a comment Amanda
stresses me she's in her sins she fights
valiantly ranking up points by the
millions just close to beating my score
but if you want to just be able to watch
your friends with Craig's right and from
earlier walks up and leans on the
pinball machine yeah we went to college
don't lean on my thing that's so
interesting CD I know things like
available honestly don't know if I could
say seriously you're gonna make it tilt
because it just seems like you're so
much work to watch after his kids don't
even go to be great if he lady I swear
to God all the sudden other sounds in
the game is over Danny made the pinball
machine tilt you still know what I said
I have to go over there now and what
weeds in my mouth so I don't say
anything that'll hurt your feelings man
no bro what's going on
that's our chant we don't get out here
we're stuck for the rest of night
wrangle Amanda and say some quick
divides with Craig head out the pizza
place finally Amanda promises that
she'll keep the couch warm for me and
heads home hope we don't mind me
bringing you back here bro not at all
dude good to finally get you all to
myself for a second River burps well
almost all of myself hold up
oh so cute wreck walked over to the
drunken scar and pulled out two gloves
in a sophomore Oh for some catch this
might be left catching more you thrown
the ball and me running after it but
shirk standing in the middle of the
empty baseball diamond and start tossing
the ball back and forth I have a cooler
in my car that we could grab but there's
only juice boxes in there man father it
is strange
nice tell me I can't believe I'm looking
back in my kegstand days and reminiscing
about it those are some of the good
times I don't know anyone else you could
pull off the rare horizontal keg stand
there's a fee to discipline bro trust me
I haven't properly hung out with Craig
and so long I didn't even know where to
begin
oh man that's about the kids can't
believe you're a father of three mom
neither can i you know me I'm an
indecisive person switch your major four
times yeah I have no idea what I wanted
to do with my life but raising kids iron
hazel was born it finally all made sense
it was like all the time I've been
trying to figure out things led to them
couldn't be happier about it I don't
think I ever cared about anything as
much as I care about them and the exact
same feeling when a man who was born was
the best thing to ever happen to me it
could be the only thing that ever
happened to me and I would still be
proud of the life I lived a softball
coach life you wanted or was it the life
that was thrust upon him I'll admit that
I was hesitant at first briar and hazel
had so much energy that we just had to
get them in this
but no one was there to run the team the
more I did it the more I saw how much
meant to all the girls
I'm worried there'd be a riot if we quit
I would also be afraid of a bunch of
tiny children with metal bats they're
quick and they work as a team I've
trained them too well it takes you down
like a pack of velociraptors on t-rex
exactly ask about the business you run a
business out dude dude yeah we sell
fitness gear imports and exports mostly
but we're coming up with our own line of
this we'll use your where soon I nod
athleisure wear that sounds too PC I
want that so badly I mostly use my
sweatpants for watching TV and whatnot
you know
sweating sounds like you'd make a
killing if you ever need athletic gear I
got your back
you could sponsor me I'll rep your
athleisure wear brand while I mow my
lawn that is the glamorous lifestyle
we're catering to yeah
nice out here quiet good to get away
from the softball moms for a bit
I don't know Christ Janet yeah knows a
lot are they always like that actually
this wasn't nearly as bad guys I'm just
so not interested well what are you
interested in peace and quiet that hot
hot Sun night my ultimate sexual fantasy
is sleeping in on a Saturday more
seriously I just can't get back into
dating right now I couldn't even if I
wanted to there's no time I feel so
uncomfortable trying to introduce a
stranger into my girls lives you've
already been through so much I can't put
them through that buddy I hear ya so the
moms can hit on me all they want but the
girls are my top priority
see Hey the right person will come along
eventually maybe he's already here you
don't have to rub whoa that was a lot
eggplants gonna have to Raj it man
things will fall into place for you
something you're gonna find someone who
cares about your kids just as much as
they care about you Oh bro
yes so sweet well I'm distracted I miss
a softball oh [ __ ] Brian Wow
that hurts man it was right all along
sorry dude Craig runs over to me oh you
okay yeah I'm fine
wait let me do the dad thing for a
second Greg spends a moment examining my
head it's worse than I thought
don't tell me you have to kiss it and
make it feel better
you would be so lucky
I mean feel like I've earned it at this
point waiting all day to hang out with
you oh well ah river is not too happy
about the fell water hey come on man or
girl
Greg leans in and kids my board walk it
off champ the lights on the softball
field really hot or is that just me I
get up and dust myself off River yawns
hey little buddy you must be getting
tired huh hey save but I should probably
head out all right things are so you get
older and life just kind of gets in the
way huh start walking back to the
parking lot and remember that one-ounce
party we went to that got broken up by
the helicopter dude you and me hopped
over a concrete wall to get away the
other side of the fence with the parking
lot where a bunch of cops were parked oh
man yeah do you imagine the look on our
faces we just walk straight past them
like we were out for a stroll now
knowing that we were at the party be
sure joking with us about how big a bust
it was I had to talk with him for 30
minutes you told them you're interested
enjoying the Academy and they started
giving me pointers for the exam long
sturdy minutes of my life man golly good
old days right I get back to our cars
Greg pulls me in for a hug or at least
as much as we can manage with a baby
between us never enough time huh guess
not oh let me make it up to you let's
hang soon yeah like Oh Greg Oh God well
I mean love yawn as I walked through the
door spotting a man hunched over collage
glue sticking and burning the midnight
our Don figured I might do something
productive between episodes of shark
hunter and lip-sync battles
the shark lips anchored to the shark
hunter slips off yes look over our
shoulder at the collage man it is some
good art that is good art you made what
good art that's great art thanks I'm
just about done look for it still a lot
of dogs and one corner has a giant pile
of cash and the other its man does that
mean yep the whole thing is about my
goals for the future and those are
basically just to sit on a giant pile of
money with my 20 dogs and also have a
strong and mutually supportive
relationship with my father into
adulthood oh now you've done it you're
ready to watch your dad grow here good
what's happening dad you did it you take
this with your good art is your fault
she passed me on the back
hey how was your hanging with Craig I
whup a tear for my eye I went 17 tears
for my it was good a Craig guy sure is
busy
yeah dude the softball light isn't for
quitters well I'm very proud of you for
facing up yours today
how's it feel well top of the world pops
which start facing my fears more often
yeah
come on tomorrow we had some empty
parking lots and practice dare I say
parallel parking baby steps man I'll
work my way up to it alright I might hit
the hay
take care of the late night television
for me alright let them know you said hi
oh that every dog exactly at every dog
please yeah ah so many points I got it
for sure
what what I think it s is a great car oh
yeah well yes that's a good place to end
this on let's see what the next screen
is though Peter well actually has a PhD
in history oh man anyway yeah oh to save
this oh that's good so anyway we just
had our first successful date with Craig
and there's gonna be a lot of dating
going on if I have to go through
everybody like this but either way thank
you everybody so much for watching I'm
gonna keep playing this in the near
future I'm gonna finish this I don't
know about 100% but I'm gonna finish
this game so thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you think
down the comments below and let me know
if you play this for yourself thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]